okay what's your name um you can call me
mali okay i'm pearl
nice to meet you so my opinion is that
in 99 of cases abortion is a cop-out so
it's a is it for a poor decision it's
interesting that you use a percentage in
an opinion in that instance because
percentages are usually used for
fact-based things and you're using using
it for an opinion so it's difficult to
kind of respond to that so if you think
that 99 of abortions are because it's
not what do you say again because often
times people bring up the exception when
i'm talking about the rule
right so so i'm saying in 99 of cases
it's it's a cop-out for poor
reproductive choices i feel like where
for me it's like this if you're going to
say 99 that means you have to have
literally either a sample group of like
literally 99 people one person or a
ratio that's equal to that and it has to
come from a valued source so unless it's
your opinion which means it's false no
it comes from data that's it comes from
data like what so in the usa like trump
posts like no no not
not trump post so no do you want to let
me talk i can tell you what's wrong so i
got it from the government website of um
of the uk and the u.s they survey
abortion clinics so people people are
surveyed as to why they get an abortion
your sample group was the uk or the u.s
both and it's similar so you sample
group the uk and what states in the u.s
so one of them was florida off the top
of my head i can't tell you every single
one calculation that you made is 99
of abortion sorry because i'm still so
again so again so so here's the thing
like i that's not the point the point
the point is that when when a woman
chooses to get an abortion outside of
grape i think it is a cop-out so and i
really would rather not go back and
forth about about great that's
completely fine i think everyone's
entitled to their opinion but the law is
completely different what is your
opinion my opinion about what abortion
yes my opinion of abortion is i've never
i've never gone through it personally
myself i'm not a woman in that instance
so i never know exactly what it's like
but if i was going to have a child that
i felt like i couldn't care for then it
would be something i would consider in
that instance if i was in that situation
so i think it's especially when america
promotes the american dream which is
meant to be freedom it's ironic that
they're taking away choice what does
that have to do with anything i just
said you don't think when we have 10
different forms of birth control so we
can get it use a condom like that's what
i'm saying i'm saying we have choice
though as women you're saying like
you're acting like women don't have
choice and i'm saying i am a woman i'm
from the us and i i have the choice i
have i i i i i okay okay
was that kind of moving so so i need you
to let me finish again we have i can use
a condom i can do abstinence i can get
the iud i think you guys call it the
coil here i can get birth control i can
get a bunch of different pills i can get
that thing you stick in your arm i can
do adoption if i want i think those are
all val i can also track when i'm
ovulating i think those are all valid
choices i think what's ironic about all
those things that you mentioned is that
you have a lesser percentage of stopping
a pregnancy than your percentage that
you have of
it's not 99 it comes to a condom it's
not nightmare it's 99 it's 99.5 when it
comes to the coil and iud okay so that's
i won it because i said the condom and
you didn't mention that at all a condom
so i kind of mentioned a condom so a
condom's 98 percent so if you do the
coil and you have a condom on nobody you
can do both it still stands if you know
what i'm saying
because that's not that's not that's not
that i said that the things that you you
okay that's not accurate because again i
also said abstinence
that's 100 you mentioned that condoms
are 98 so if 98 percent chance that
someone's going to be pregnant
no no it's not if if there's 98 chance
uh no there's a two percent chance that
someone could be pregnant with using the
condom but that's not an effective form
of contraception if i can't have an
abortion based off the fact that 99 of
abortion 99 of child
pregnancies that i want to
so yeah what's what about abstinence i
don't know absolutely what
not having sex what percent what percent
of pregnancies does that prevent i mean
abstinence is not really part of the
question that's like a random variable
that's like it is because i listed that
as a form of birth control you this
abstinence is a form of birth control
yeah what is abstinence to you bro what
are you talking about man not having sex
what personally anyone can yeah so
you're going to say
if you're going to promote abstinence
that's a choice
okay let me just think of a perfect
metaphor so another another stat that
people don't realize is 40 of women that
get abortions have had two or more both
in the uk you can look that up that's on
a uk government website and in the u.s
and they don't and so and they track
they track they track and they they
don't track the 60 if they're going to
have abortions in the future that's
great so what do you think so
abstinence do you think that's a natural
thing do i think it's a natural thing no
i think i think abstinence is very hard
he thinks the unnatural thing so what's
ironic about that is you promote that as
a solution
one of one of
no no this is my channel this is my
channel this guy frustrated me because
i hate it when interviewees come up to
me and tell me how to interview them and
try to tell me what we're going to talk
about no this is my channel
i get to pick what we're talking about
not you
so yeah i had to i had to let him go
because he wasn't listening he wasn't
listening this is this is this is my
channel this is my channel you're coming
to my job okay so i'm saying again i
that was one of many options that i
could like i mentioned but you
disregarded so you said you stuck on
abstinence so is this the slave
abstinence i i i i mentioned eight
different forms but you refused but you
refused initially hit me out when i said
condoms so they stick with abstinence
because you push abstinence we have
video evidence what i'm saying so they
stick to abstinence so you said it's not
a natural thing you know what i'm saying
but the whole thing about this whole
abortion thing is how it's unnatural say
i think i think abortions are unnatural
and that's your kind of argument for it
but when you're promoting the solution
to being unnatural things is
hypocritical no no no no i i promoted
eight i promoted eight forms of
contraceptives
that is one of eight that's two things
as two of eight that i find hypocritical
because condoms are 98
again you're talking about so so this is
this is this is the problem is you're
looking for exceptions we're talking
about the rule so
that's that's you're talking about
exceptions when we're talking about the
rules so you have a 98 you even with
condoms you have a 98 chance of not
getting pregnant that's pretty good odds
so i'm saying that if you don't want to
use condoms you also have you also have
abstinence you can also get an iud you
can use a coil you can use birth control
you can do the thing
that is if my primary goal is to not get
pregnant what my primary goal is to have
sex and not have a pregnancy you take
you're removing you're removing very no
so then so so then you should use the
eight forms of contraception that we
have i should constantly use the eight
forms of contraception if i plan to have
sex even though one of those forms of
contraception is to not have sex you're
hypocritical it's interesting
how
liberals always bring up the exception
always always always always it's never
the this is a new term that someone in
the comment section said and i thought
it was so true they said the exception
does not disprove the rule and it's true
it's true what do you understand what
i'm saying that's a contradiction if
you're going to say that abstinence i'm
saying abstinence is one i'm saying
abstinence is one one of the eight yes
which is one of the eight things that
i'm going to like you've recommended to
me to control my con as contraception no
i'm i'm saying i'm saying it's one of
many so if you don't want to do
abstinence you can get the coil which is
99.5 percent effective the point is you
don't want to do the coil you can get
you can do birth control if you don't
want to get the birth control you can
you can get an eye you can get some that
thing that they stick into your arm i
forgot the name if you don't want to do
that there's adoption like there's
always a fail safe and the and the issue
that i have is you're taking
accountability off of women when it's
they're making a poor decision half and
half like again like like like they'd be
like you're arguing with me over one
percent 99 versus yeah because you are
because you keep is for the whole 100
not the 99 percent the law is for 100 of
the people on this planet so you make
law for that you make you make laws
based on the you make you make laws
based on the rules and not the
exceptions
and who said that
why would you do do you think that you
should make laws based on the exception
um if you try if you try and make me say
some things that are not true but i
never mentioned asking you that's
actually relevant to this conversation
because you did you talking about rules
come from what was that statement
i said
laws are based on the rule they're not
based on the exception whose words are
those yours
i would say that the laws are based off
of the rule not the acceptance speaking
because so so
so
this is what we're here to talk about
opinions
so
the reason why it got difficult is
because you use percentages in opinions
okay so so again you're arguing with me
over two percent
and so that's like like when it comes to
law like it's for 100 so you can't
literally just i'm saying we make laws
based on the rule not the exception
you're arguing for 98. i'm arguing for
100. you understand you're saying it's 2
that's your perception
so so again again you're not even
debating me on what we're trying to talk
about
so so okay okay so so because of that
i'm going to go on to the next person
but thank you for stopping i appreciate
it
have a great one okay thank you